>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Pause ]
>> Eugene Flanagan: Hello.
I'm Eugene Flanagan,
Director of National Programs
at The Library of Congress.
And it's my pleasure to
welcome you here this afternoon
to Spotlight on Native Writers.
The event is sponsored
by The Library's Poetry
and Literature Center, home to
among other programs The Library
of Congress Prize for
American Fiction presented
in 2010 to Louise Erdrich.
Last fall Erdrich participated
in a terrific session
of the National Book
Festival, and we are excited
to have today's event occurring in
conjunction with Erdrich's return
to the Capitol for the debut of
her new novel, and you'll hear more
about that later from Rob
Caspar, the Head of the Center.
Spotlight on Native
Writers gives The Library
of Congress an opportunity
to feature a few
of the many essential Native
literary voices active today.
And Erdrich has prefaced today's
event with the observation that,
and I quote, bringing our
contemporary Native stories to life
in one of our country's
greatest institutions is a worthy
and delightful enterprise.
Helping us today in that enterprise,
that delightful enterprise, right,
are our four guests,
three on the stage now.
Eric Gansworth is an artist and
author of 10 novels and a play.
In the fall Eric will be
NEH Visiting Professor
of Native American Studies
at Colgate University.
His next novel is Give
Me Some Truth.
Linda LeGarde Grover is a
writer and poet and the winner
of the Flannery O'Connor Award.
Linda is a Professor of American
Indian Studies at the University
of Minnesota, Duluth, and her next
poetry collection is titled The
Sky Watched.
Stephen Graham Jones is
the author of 16 novels
and six short story collections.
Stephen teaches in the FMA programs
of the University of Colorado
at Boulder and the University of
California, Riverside-Palm Desert,
and his current novel is Mongrels.
Following readings by Eric,
Linda and Stephen we will have a
moderated discussion led by poet
and scholar, Deborah Miranda.
Deborah is the John Lucian Smith
[Assumed Spelling] Junior Professor
of English at Washington and
Lee University and author
of three books of poetry.
Her next book is collection
of essays, The Hidden Stories
of Isabelle Meadows and Other
California Indian Lucini
[Assumed Spelling].
But before we start, some logistics.
Please turn off your cell phones
and all electronic devices.
If you have questions
during the q-and-a portion
of the program please wait for
us to give you a portable mike.
Also, please note that
by participating
in the q-and-a session you give The
Library permission to include you
in future audio and webcasts.
When the program concludes there
will be a book signing by all
of our authors at the back
of the room, with Josh there.
And to find out more about the
Poetry and Literature Center
in general or this program please
visit our website at loc.gov/poetry.
But now please join me in
welcoming Eric Gansworth,
Linda LeGarde Grover, Stephen
Graham Jones, and Deborah Miranda.
[ Applause ]
[ Pause ]
>> Eric Gansworth: Good afternoon.
Thank you for coming.
Thank you to The Library
of Congress for inviting me
to participate in this event.
It's really delightful to
be here on the same occasion
as Louse's new novel being launched,
which I'm sure many people are very
excited about, as much as I am.
I'm going to read an excerpt
from a forthcoming
novel, Give Me Some Truth.
It is a follow-up to my last
novel, If I Ever Get Out of Here.
I'm working on a four-novel
sequence of Beatle's books.
I'm not really sure what's going
to happen when we get to Ringo,
but so this is the first chapter
from this narrative point of view,
this is the John and Yoko book
so they get equal billing.
And so this is from a 15-year-old
girl who is a bead worker.
Are you from an Indian reservation
near here, the new groom asked,
while his bride eyed up a pair
of beadwork dangle
earrings from our display.
Technically, my sister Marie said.
Immediately new groom's
ears perked up.
He clearly didn't want to
be buying fake Indian goods.
Either you are or you aren't
Indian, isn't that right, he asked.
Our mom was walking back
from the lady's room,
a half million miles
from our vendor's table.
Marie never engaged in her mild
sabotage when our mom was around.
It was Memorial Day weekend,
the beginning of our season
selling handmade Indian souvenirs
at Niagara Falls State Park.
We personally enforced
our tribal treaties
with the likes of New York State.
It gives you a sense of power
in your otherwise woefully
powerless 15-year-old girl life.
Oh, yeah, we are definitely
Indian, Marie said,
don't my beautiful
red skin prove it?
New groom was edgy, but new bride
had already locked her tractor beam
eyes on the earrings.
We just don't live
on the reservation
anymore, but I wish we did.
Most of our family does,
and I'm tired of living
in the city, Marie said.
Suddenly switching
to her forlorn tone.
Our mom greeted our
potential customers
with the humble Indian craftsperson
face she had mastered years ago.
We longed to be among our people,
I said, going along with Marie.
Trying out new routines
could be fun.
So why aren't you among your
people, new groom asked.
A lot of tourists ask
this pushy question,
testing to see if we
were real Indians.
Our vendor permit was pinned
to the appropriately ingenie
[Assumed Spelling] Pendleton
covering our table.
The Parks Department required
it be visible at all times,
the permit, not the Pendleton.
Sad fact, I said, adopting my own
version of forlorn Indian, Indians,
they don't buy much beadwork.
A little lie, they tended to buy
only a certain kind of beadwork.
Keychains, trucker caps or baseball
caps, disposable lighter cases,
bingo bags and eyeglass cases.
So here we are building bridges to
the larger culture with our art.
I modeled my look on the
crying antipollution TV Indian.
This broach is designed by my
elders to go with the earrings.
I slid a little basswood
carving forward.
My dad made it last week.
The expression on new bride's
face said she couldn't see herself
in this combo.
She didn't love Indians that much.
This is our specialty, I added,
revealing one of our canoes,
which I did whenever
I saw that expression.
In my best mystical Indian
voice, all clipped confidence
and draggy vowels,
the works, I said,
each Indian family has
their own signature,
ours is the double heart canoe,
very popular among honeymooners.
This was a phrase I usually closed
the deal with, chopping out my y's
and pronouncing popular
like a variety of tree.
You can spot honeymooner
hands immediately.
New bride usually fans her
fingers like piano players,
hoping you'll ask about
her engagement ring
so she can tell you all
the carats and setting.
New groom is usually spinning
his new ring with his thumb,
the way you might absently
work a burst blister.
They wanted something
we could provide.
Maintaining our tables we kept
the porter agreement alive.
You can bet official parks
vendors had tried for years
to justify breaking that treaty.
What I had said, though, a
sales pitch was still true,
the double heart canoe
was our signature item.
You do best with something that's
like traditional Indian beadwork,
but that also commemorates
something for the tourists.
I helped design this.
My family developed the beadwork
equivalent of the concert T-shirt,
with tour dates and
cities on the back.
You see, Niagara Falls is official
honeymoon capitol of the world.
I'm not sure why a giant waterfall
above a bunch of sharp rocks made
that cut, maybe because when people
get married they say they're taking
the plunge.
Together we came up
with this killer idea
for the schatzki inclined
newlywed tourists.
My dad made little birch bark canoes
that my mom stuffed two plump
velvet heart pincushions inside of.
We beaded the hearts with a date and
initials while the customer watched.
I've carved so many initials and
hash marks into little hearts
that I could maybe qualify as a
graffiti minded cardiac surgeon.
Despite our signature,
our mom left our dad,
his rental shack when I was eight.
Our apartment was in
something called the projects,
which made it seem like we lived
in a classroom science experiment.
Add an Indian woman
and her kids to a set
of low rent apartment buildings
jammed with too many people,
all colors except white,
what happens?
Do they bind and make
a new substance?
If so, is it like epoxy or acid?
Even after we moved out my
parents shared the treaty
and short vendor permit, and
my mom still sold my dad's work
since you needed a res address
to apply for the permit.
At first they refused to collaborate
on the double heart canoes.
They each insisted they were
stuck with the hard part and,
thus, should get a bigger cut.
None of us kids dared suggest
we had the hardest part.
Though it was true,
we had to chit-chat
with the newly in-love couples while
we maimed velvet hearts for them.
The city wasn't a bad
place to finish out school,
and we did the same vendor table
gig we'd always done in the summers.
It was like being near
a satellite reservation,
at least in the summertime.
The reservation heavy tavern
softball league teams played
in the park near the projects.
There were worse ways to spend your
summer evenings than watching men
in tight uniforms running
around, every now
and then rearranging their favorite
equipment inside those tight pants.
Oh, hon, the new bride
said, isn't this the cutest?
While new groom glanced at
the canoe, suddenly searching
for a hangtag to see what
it was going to cost.
We could smudge it with
some tobacco, Marie said,
reaching under the
table for her purse
where I knew she had
a pack of Kool's.
Get you off on the right foot
for a lifetime of happiness.
Is that extra, new groom asked?
He had not yet learned his lines.
My daughter jokes, our mom said,
kicking Marie under the table,
just like on a sitcom except there
was no joke there, no stunt kicks.
We do, though, offer to bead
your initials and the date,
usually $10 extra, but this
beautiful Memorial Day,
she said opening her arms wide
to provide her generosity,
we give you that part for free.
Oh, hon, new bride said.
And new groom got out his wallet.
My blushing bride here, he
said, grabbing her shoulders
and squeezing her close to him,
she's a DAR, so her mother wanted us
to get married on the 4th of July.
DAR, our mom said, burning
through her gas tank of charm,
your name is Darlene, Darla?
D-A-R, new bride said giggling,
Daughters of the American
Revolution.
It was important to my
mother, she hastened to add,
my parents wanted us to get
married on the 4th of July,
invite all their other DAR friends.
We're from Concord.
Apparently that was supposed
to mean something to us.
But we're not really like that.
Then she leaned in conspiratorially,
we eloped to avoid a big production.
So nice to have a memento.
If they want to throw us a reception
on Independence Day, great,
but we get to be married
where and when we want.
We've got beaded picture
frames, too,
I said to new groom,
upping the ante.
Make great thank you gifts
for your new in-laws.
Got some here with two
beaded birds, like lovebirds.
I hated using poor grammar, but it
tended to make the sale smoother.
I revealed an elaborate
velvet beadwork picture frame.
The bride ran her fingers over the
rich velvet, leaving little trails.
I could even bead a couple
little bees on it, I said,
joining her giggle, since this is
your honeymoon, birds and bees.
New groom grinned.
Not sure your mother would
care for that, he laughed.
My mom was about to blow a gasket
thinking I'd lost the sale.
Might be kind of a fun
secret joke, he added,
how long before it could be ready?
Fifteen minutes, I said, I could
do this beading in my sleep.
Half hour, our mom interrupted,
handing the double heart canoe
to Marie and digging
out her receipt book.
My daughters work quick, but
it's very trick work, she said,
doing a double drop y, as I had.
I made big eyes at Marie.
My mom asked for 50% down since
we couldn't sell it to anyone else
with their initials on it.
The groom, still chuckling about
the secret sexy joke he'd be playing
on his mother-in-law,
said he'd pay in full.
When our mom got their initials
for the custom beading
she showed him the receipt
with $100 in the total line.
His eyes bugged, but I was
already breaking out my yellow
and black beads to do
a couple quick bumbles.
He paid and they watched their art
being created right before their
eyes, commemorating their day.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Linda LeGarde Grover: Ojou
[Assumed Spelling], everybody.
Linda Grover [inaudible].
And I'm going to read the
introductory part to my book,
The Road Back to Sweetgrass,
and then a part
of a chapter depending
on how the time looks.
So we start out this way,
the introduction is
called The Odissimaa Bag.
Today, the opening day of the Mozhay
Point Ojibwe Reservations wild rice
harvest, cumulous clouds drift
slowly over the boat landing
on Lost Lake, bringing with
them the scent of sweetgrass.
Among the ricers, who pause
to inhale the blessing,
are a teenage boy and his father,
who park at the side of the road
in a gray primered Ford truck faded
to the near no-color of glass.
A young married couple, who argue
as they carry her parents'
canoe toward the water,
and an elderly woman, who has just
placed a pot of coffee to boil
on an old car grill over a campfire.
On this western edge of Mozhay
it happens that way occasionally,
when the wind comes
from the northeast,
the scent of sweetgrass
edging and swirling
from the LeForest [Assumed
Spelling] family allotment land,
its source somewhere near
the maple sugar bush,
making its invisible way past
the cabin and down the driveway
to the road where it
dissipates and fades
when it reaches the boat landing.
The Mozhay Point ricers, who
know that no sweetgrass grows
on the LeForest land even
in the swamp on the far side
of the allotment, occasionally stop
in their work to wonder about this.
But the scent reminds us that
we've been blessed by the Creator
in all ways, understood or
otherwise, here during our time
on Mother Earth, and so we accept
the mystery for what it is.
And yet in the old muskrat family
sugar bush, there near the middle
of the land that more than a century
ago became the LeForest family land
allotment is where spirits tread so
lightly that their feet transparent
as the air make no more mark
on the ground than air, itself.
With every step the scent invisibly
compressed and released renews
and rises into LeForest
allotment atmosphere.
And the earth that is covered by
leaves in fall, snow in winter,
mud in spring, and sparse
northern moss in summer.
A small deerskin bag
sewn with red thread
and blue beads holds an
infant's umbilical cord
and Odissimaa wrapped
in dried sweetgrass.
This chapter is called
In Her Dream Margie.
The young Margie Robineau,
moving through the landscape
of her early-morning dreams,
knew as well as a much older woman
all the songs and where they ended.
She had danced this
one a hundred times.
As it neared the tail, the last
minute of the fugue of drumbeat
and voices, she danced nearer to the
men at the drum, who in anticipation
of the quickening of the pace leaned
forward on their folding chairs.
The lead singer bent to pick a
Styrofoam cup up from the floor
with his left hand, his right hand
holding the drumstick in midair
as he swallowed a mouthful of
water between skipped beats.
He cupped his left hand to hear,
his ear, as he raised his voice.
The pitch, a wolf singing into
the wind, striking the drum harder
with every other beat, volume
muffled by the sheepskin wrapping
on the end of the drumstick to
a deep boom, felt by the girl
who was Margie, Margie Endus
[Assumed Spelling] at the back
of the curved arabesque
of her ribs as she danced.
She watched Jowosh's
[Assumed Spelling] head bob,
now his white hair reflecting
the fluorescent lighting
of the gymnasium ceiling
to the silver of Lost Lake
under a full moon in winter.
Now as the fugue bent,
dipped, turned the corner
into the tail of the song, now.
The girl's gaze turned from
the singers to the blur
of the powwow circle then inward.
Her feet stayed with the drum, out
of her sight but seen in her mind
as she danced, moccasins beaded with
blue skies and rivers, green leaves
and vines, flowers the color of
late summer, prancing and stepping,
kicking and turning, sending her
prayers to the Creator by way
of skies and rivers, leaves,
vines and flowers of late summer.
When the song ended her
practiced feet hit the ground
on the last beat, side by side,
together, toes first, heels grounded
on the last split second.
Hewa [Assumed Spelling],
Jowosh didn't say it out loud.
She woke to the hesitant gurgle of
the toilet flushing weak and thin
on the other side of her bedroom
wall as the middle-aged Margie,
who duct-taped her large supports
into her dance boots as she dressed
for grand entry and who needed
more than six hours of sleep.
Half opening her eyes to the
osmotic fogginess of the beginnings
of illumination, that gray
light that seeps into rooms
where morning sleepers
endeavor to extend the night.
She blinked at probing fingers
of reality, forcing daylight
through slats of drawn
vinyl window blinds,
prying apart the crack
between drawn curtains.
Did I dance like that, she wondered?
Am I young?
No, she remembered, I
have a daughter older
than I was in the dream.
Crystal jiggled the flush handle
to stop the irritatingly apologetic
sound of the running toilet.
She coughed, deep and dry.
Wrestled cellophane,
her pack of Camels.
Lit a match, sucked smoke, exhaled.
Passing the bedroom door she looked
in to see if her mother was awake.
Her left hand was cupped over her
mouth, cigarette between her second
and third fingers,
filter close to her lips.
Margie saw an old man's
silhouette, short-legged and skinny,
with those stringy muscular
arms standing in the doorway
to the bedroom, gray and
indistinct, an aberration.
Jowosh? Margie rubbed the back
of her wrist against her eyes.
The aberration stretched,
crossed its wrists
above its head and
became her daughter.
Oh, I'm in Aunt Beryl's [Assumed
Spelling] trailer, she remembered,
not in the allotment house.
I live here.
Joe lives at the hospital
in convalescent care.
You up, Crystal asked.
How late did you work?
Almost two, busy at Chiwadek
[Assumed Spelling] last night.
Where were you?
Out. With who?
Just out. She glared at her
mother, none of your business.
Did you find out about
blackjack training?
Coughed, dropped her cigarette.
Watch the rug.
No, they haven't decided yet if
they're going to have the class.
Where's auntie Beryl?
Down at the boat landing.
Hey, I'm going to go down there,
see if I can find a ricing partner.
Can I borrow the rowboat,
use Michael's stuff,
his duckbill and knockers?
I know he's not there.
I'm broke.
You look like hell, who
would want to rice with you?
Are you hung-over?
Well, what do you think?
Crystal gulped, swallowing
back the dry heaves.
Go ahead, it's Michael's
stuff, not mine,
take whatever you want,
he's not around.
The young woman went back into
Beryl's squirrely bathroom.
She ran water noisily into
the sink while she wretched.
Took deep breaths to
settle her stomach.
Ah, Pepto-Bismol, she thought.
There was a bottle in
the medicine cabinet.
She took two chalky
peppermint swallows
from the bottle and wretched again.
Knelt on the floor to see if
she had heaved pink liquid
on the matching pink shag bathmat.
She held a wet washcloth
over her face,
counted to 10, and cautiously stood.
Lifting the washcloth she
saw herself, slack faced,
staring out at the mirror with
eyes that looked like two pee holes
in the snow, as Margie would say.
Above the reflection showed her two
impossibly pretty Indians embraced,
a vaguely effeminate brave and a
Nordic featured princess simpering
in front of a pink and gold sunset.
Auntie Beryl had won the laminated
plaque at Saturday Night Fever bingo
and hung it in the bathroom
where it could be seen twice,
on the wall and in the mirror.
Ick, she muttered.
She sipped water from the
plastic cup shaped like a rosebud.
Crystal, her mother said when
she came out of the bathroom,
I've been thinking about us moving
back into the allotment house.
Michael is just about never there
and even when he is he sleeps
in the shed most of the time anyway.
It doesn't even have a furnace.
Ah, but even in winter it's
plenty warm with the woodstove
and then we'd have our own place.
We did fine there before we
moved in with Auntie Beryl.
We could take care of it, you and
me, it just needs a little work.
And take a chance into
running into Michael,
that bum who couldn't be
bothered by his own daughter?
It's a wreck, it has
raccoons under the stairs.
God, no thanks.
Let Michael deal with that place.
Beryl needs you here.
Now that the weather is still nice,
we could try it again, Crystal,
do a little work, get
it ready for the winter.
Jowosh would like that.
God, I'm going to the landing.
Crystal picked up her cigarettes
and lighter from the kitchen counter
and walked out, letting
the door slam.
At the bottom of the steps
she spun around and went back
into the kitchen to take her
plaid flannel shirt from the hook
by the door and a piece
of left-over fry bread
from the bowl on the table.
That's yesterday's,
cautioned Margie.
I'll eat it before
I get to the road.
Crystal squeezed her
mother's shoulder,
you know the cabin is
a dump, see you later.
At the bottom of the stairs she
called back, they'd better let you
into Blackjack training,
those bastards.
If they're letting Theresa do
it they'd better let you, too.
She walks, as she always
did, quickly,
impatiently with a long
short-legged stride
down the driveway and to the road.
As Margie absentmindedly
bit into a piece
of day-old fry bread
she wondered to herself
when the cabin's barrel
stove had been last cleaned
and if the back door had
been properly latched?
One of the worst things
to do once it gets cold,
cleaning up after a dirty stove in a
freezing room, she said to herself.
Even worse if a raccoon gets in.
She microwaved a cup of instant
coffee, positioned her arch supports
into Jowosh's old moccasins
that waited for her feet.
Then, still in her pajamas,
sat outside on the log-splitting
stump dunking day-old fry bread
and contemplating the cutoff path
that led from Beryl's trailer back
to the LeForest allotment house.
[Indian] Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Pause ]
>> Stephen Graham Jones: Hello.
You all can hear me, yes?
All right.
You'll notice I skated in
at the last possible moment.
There's a lot of knife
drama with getting
into this building
evidently, you know?
But nobody got cut or
threatened or anything.
Really, when it showed up in my
inbox asking me to come here,
like I had the idea that The Library
of Congress was like an abstract,
I thought it was an idea.
I didn't know it was a
physical place, you know?
So coming here it's like
I'm going to a fake -
like stepping into a
platonic ideal kind of,
it's kind of cool, I like it.
Thank you, all, for coming out.
Thank you, all, for hosting.
This is really a cool,
cool thing to do.
And I want to read you all a little
bit from my new novel, Mongrels,
and also thank you all for
letting me read here because I get
to hang-out with my
editor who got the book,
for like three minutes
I get to see her later.
It's going to be cool, you know?
All you need to know at this point
in the novel is werewolves are real,
and there's an uncle named Darren,
an aunt named Libby, and a kid,
he's 14 years old, he's waiting to
see if he's got the blood or not,
if he's a werewolf or not.
And I forgot my glasses,
so this could be fun,
and I'm on the wrong page, too.
Hold on, hold on.
This is only my third time
to read from this book.
Today is the actual official
launch date for this book.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
This is from a chapter
titled American Ninja.
Did you all watch American
Ninja coming up, any of you all?
Michael Dudikoff, he can
kick like anybody in the face
and that solves all problems, right?
That's pretty cool.
All right.
We're werewolves.
Each night at dusk one of us leans
out the door to burn the trash.
Just because we all
know what can happen
if that trash is left
in the kitchen.
Somebody will go wolf in the night.
And because shifting burns up every
last bit of fat reserves you have
and even leaves you
in the hole for more,
the first thing you
think once you're a wolf,
the only thing you can think if
you're just starting out is food.
It's not a choice,
it's just survival.
You eat whatever is there and fast,
be it the people sleeping around you
at the rest stop or if
you get a trailer rented
for four months, the kitchen trash.
It sounds stupid, but it's true.
When we first open our eyes as
werewolves the trash is so fragrant,
so perfect, so right
there, except there's things
in there you can't digest, I
don't care how bad you are.
Ever wake with the ragged
lid of a tin can in your gut?
Darren says it's like a circle
saw blade in first gear,
but it's only because you're so
delicate in the morning, so human.
Even a twist-tie can stab through
the lining of your stomach.
The wolf doesn't know any better,
just knows to eat it
all and fast and now.
Come daylight, though, so
many werewolves die this way,
Libby had told me, so many die
with a broke tined
fork stabbing them open
from the middle, from the inside.
With a discarded whole
beef rib pushing
through their spleen,
their pancreas.
She said she even heard of
somebody dying from a housedog
that had had its pelvis put
together with a metal rod.
The metal rod, it went down
the wolf's throat fine,
along with the crunchy domestic
bones, but in the morning
for the man it was a spear.
Libby had stopped meaningfully
on spear, settled me in her stare
to make sure I was paying
the right kind of attention.
I had been, sort of.
Because I was sure I was going
to shift just any night now,
was going to pad on all
fours down the long hall
from my bedroom at any moment.
Sniff at the coffee table,
then turn my attention
to the much richer
scent of the kitchen,
because that was definitely
going to happen.
I always lug the trash out.
Never mind that Libby had always
been careful to not leave steel wool
or bleach containers in there.
Never mind that we kept a jug
of black pepper right there
on the counter to sprinkle on to the
trash as it built through the day.
I'd be able to smell
through that, I knew.
I was going to be that
kind of werewolf,
in spite of Libby's prayers.
The life she wanted for me, it
was a life my mom should have had,
the life that her not being a
werewolf should have been mine
by birthright, but
something had gone haywire.
Just once, just waiting, though.
That was the part her and
Darren couldn't figure.
I had the blood, but was
that blood ever going to rise
or had it been a onetime thing?
With grandpa five years gone there
weren't even any old-timers to ask,
did this happen before, had
there ever been somebody like me?
There had to have been.
Werewolves have always been here.
Every variation of us, it has
to have happened at some point.
Just it's the remembering
that's tricky.
Until we knew for sure one way or
the other Libby was packing my head
with facts, like trying to
scare me back across the line.
driving here from East Texas, the
big Delta 88 eating up the miles,
the trunk empty because all our
stuff had burned a move or two ago.
She'd evened her voice out to
sound like a safety pamphlet
and recounted all the
ways we usually die.
It was the werewolf version of The
Talk, just with more dead bodies.
It took nearly the whole 10 hours,
no radio, no books, nothing.
I stared a hole into the dashboard,
not wanting to let her see
how perfect all this was,
how much I was loving every
single wonderful fact.
She had already told
me about the trash.
The rest, though, being
a werewolf it's a game
of Russian roulette,
Darren would say.
It's waking up every morning
with that gun to your temple.
And then he'd snap
his teeth over the end
of that sentence and
give a yip or two.
And I'd have to look away so
Libby wouldn't see me smiling.
I wanted to be him so bad.
But trash isn't the only way we go.
The modern world its custom
design to kill werewolves.
There's French-fries for one.
The idea, Libby said,
switching hands
on the Delta 88's thin steering
wheel and steering straight ahead,
boring holes into the
night with her eyes -
the idea is werewolves think
they'll burn all those calories
up the next time they shift.
And they're not wrong, you burn up
your French-fry calories and more.
But calories aren't the
dangerous part of the French-fry,
the dangerous part of the French-fry
is that once you have a taste
for them then running around in a
pasture one night chasing wild boar
or digging up rabbits or
whatever, all honest work,
you'll catch that salty
scent on the air.
If you still had your human
mind you'd know not to chase
that scent down, you'd know better.
You're not thinking
like that, though.
You run like smoke through
the trees, over the fences,
and when you find those French-fries
they're usually on a picnic table
in some deserted place,
which is a dream, right?
Except for the couple sitting on
opposite sides of that picnic table.
They can be young and broke,
having had to dig into couches
for enough change for this
weekly basket of fries to split
out at their favorite place.
Or they can be the 50-year
anniversary set indulging themselves
on exactly the kind
of greasy fat they're
under strict orders
to stay away from.
What they should really stay
away from, it turns out,
is eating those French-fries
out in the open.
They don't know they live
in a world with werewolves.
By the time they do
know it's too late.
Blind with hunger you
barrel up under that table
and snatch the fries
in a single motion.
I've eaten them bag
and all by the time
that picnic table is two
leaping bounds behind you.
At which point you register
that distinct flavor of salt
on this couple's fingertips,
as well, around their lips.
Your paws skid in the gravel,
the dust under that gravel rising
in a plume, you're about to
rip open, explode back through.
The newspaper the next day
won't show crime scene photos
of the remains or the blood
splashed picnic table.
You won't need them.
You'll have those photographs
in your head already.
And those kind of visual flashes
Darren says you get in the daytime,
like half-remembered dreams.
And you'll think French-fries.
And the next time you follow that
salty scent in from the pasture,
an honest rabbit dangling limp
from either side of your jowls,
that two-lane highway you have to
cross to get to that tanginess,
maybe this time there'll be a
semi hurtling down the near lane,
it's grill guard thick
and purposeful.
Or there'll be men on the roof
of the cinderblock bathroom,
their rifles waiting,
obituaries folded
in their tall leather wallets.
I'm going to skip a page here
because I don't want
to go over my time.
This is another way they die,
there's a lot of ways they die.
There's not an easy
way to transition
to this, so I'll just jump in.
Frankenstein didn't have to worry
about Lycra, though, or spandex.
Stretch pants are just as
dangerous to werewolves as highways.
Libby is always careful
to wear denim
and Darren wouldn't be caught
dead in anything but jeans.
Me either.
The good thing about jeans
is that they rip-away.
Not at the seams, like you'd think,
that yellow thread there
is tough like fishing line.
In the center of the denim,
where it's worn the thinnest.
It sucks always having to
buy new ones or finding ones
at the [inaudible] store
with long enough legs,
but that's just part
of being a werewolf.
A pair of tights, though,
man, pantyhose are murder.
Libby had only heard
about this, never seen it,
but supposedly what can happen is
you've wriggled into a pair of hose
or tights, except for color I really
don't understand the difference
between the two, and then over
the course of the day they're
such a constant annoyance
that you kind
of forget about them all together.
Enter night then, begin
the transformation.
Where pants will tear away,
split over the thigh and calf,
burst at the waist no matter
how double-riveted they are,
your fancy pantyhose, your stretch
pants they wolf out with you.
I'd imagine you look kind of stupid
with your legs all sheer and shiny,
but anybody who laughs you
just rip their throat out,
feast on their heart,
problem solved.
At least until morning
when you shift back.
Just like that tick that impacted
itself into grandpa's skin,
a pair of pantyhose, they'll
retract with your legs.
Except instead of one tick
embedding itself in your skin,
flaring into some infection,
this time every hair is pulling
something back in with it.
What happens is your skin, your
human skin is part pantyhose now.
Like the hose have melted on
to you, but deeper than deep.
And because you just used all
your calories shifting back,
it's not easy like on television.
And because you're hurt now you
probably can't go back to wolf yet,
can't get tough enough to sustain
this kind of all-over injury.
Worst, this isn't an immediate
death, you linger through the day.
If your family, your
werewolf family,
if they really love you
they'll end it for you.
If you're alone then its hours
of trying to pull those pantyhose
up from your bloody skin.
Its fine, slippery threads of
that hose ducking into your veins
and getting pumped
higher into your body.
If you're lucky one of those
clumps makes its way to your brain.
If you're not lucky then you end
up trying to use your human teeth
to peel-up all the skin
from the top of your thigh,
the back of your calf,
wherever you can reach.
It doesn't help.
I don't know what the
coroner calls these kind
of deaths, probably drug psychosis.
Obvious enough to him that a
blood test isn't even necessary.
Look at this trailer, this living
room, how they were living.
Look at how she was
picking at her skin.
Bag her up, team, and drop
a match on your way out.
But there's another way we die,
too, the oldest way maybe -
which is in the rest of the book.
Thank you, all.
[ Applause ]
>> Deborah Miranda: Thank you,
everybody, that was really terrific.
My name is Deborah Miranda.
I'm from the Ohlone-Costanoan
Esselen Nation
of the Greater Monterrey Bay Area.
So I am a long way
from home right now.
Never in a million years did I
think I would be standing here
at an indigenous panel in The
Library of Congress in Washington,
D.C. Washington, D.C. is a city
that's been the source of a lot
of devastating legislature
for Native Americans,
legislature that was meant
to separate Native people
from our lands, our
cultures and even our lives.
My own people, a conglomeration
of California Indian tribes,
were on the receiving end of
nearly $2 million of bonds approved
by Congress to fund extermination
of tribes in California
that were blocking various
kinds of American expansion.
So our population plummeted from
about one million pre-contact
to 5,000 to 10,000 150 years later.
A lot of that was funded
right here in Washington,
D.C. But the good news is I'm here
and we are here, and a large part
of that is due to some pretty
innovative survival techniques.
So we're still here and
we're still telling stories.
My first question that I have
for this crew here, I wanted to -
I was thinking about something
that Elizabeth Cookland
[Assumed Spelling] said,
she's Crow Creek Lakota
Native poet and writer,
and she said that any nation
that does not tell its own
stories cannot actually say,
claim that status of being a nation,
if you let somebody else tell your
stories then you've already lost.
And I was wondering what you think
about that statement from Liz,
who is a fairly well known
person as well as writer?
So what do you think
about that saying?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: I guess
I pretty much always disagree
with everything she says.
I probably disagree
with it, finally.
>> Deborah Miranda: I
think the word people use
for her is polemic,
that's the polite word.
Eric, how about you?
>> Eric Gansworth:
Well, it's very extreme
and I think that's
sort of her signature.
There's just so much more nuance
in what we do that I just -
I think that it doesn't really leave
a lot of room for other people.
>> Stephen Graham Jones:
That's the trick,
the leaving room is the hard part
because people always want to build
like exclusive clubs
on top of a mountain
that only certain people can get
into, and it seems like a lot
of her stuff does that, you know?
>> Linda LeGarde Grover: I'd like
to say something, but I can't figure
out how - oh, I bet it's
this thing, you think so?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: A
lifesaver, it's on the bottom.
>> Linda LeGarde Grover:
I think it's this one.
All right, thank you so much.
I wonder if perhaps
what she is saying is -
she's certainly never met my dad,
who lived way up in
Northern Minnesota there.
but what he used to tell us in
experiences that we were having
and some were great and
some were not so great,
but he would always
say make it your own.
And so, you know, just kind
of take it and make it part
of the greater experience
and whether you actually
purposely tell a story
or not these things do become
part of the larger story.
I'm not sure what he would have
said if he read this quote,
but I think he would have encouraged
us to remember, to always remember,
and that at some point the time
will be right to make it yours,
use it for the best way
and perhaps pass it on.
>> Deborah Miranda: Well, I
think that's a great point
because I think what
Cookland forgets there is
that sometimes Native
people are put in a position
where they are not allowed to speak,
cannot speak, and so you don't speak
because you need to
save your life, right?
Stephen, what were you going to say?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: I was going
to say that I do usually disagree
with Cookland on pretty much
everything, but I'm glad she's
out there because she gives
us like a rallying point
to negatively define ourselves
against, which is fun.
I like that, you know?
You can drop anything she
says in any conversation
and you've got three
hours of conversation
after that, which is good I think.
I'm glad she's doing
what she's doing.
She's not here, is she?
>> Deborah Miranda: Would it matter?
That's why they took
your knife away.
Okay, my second question
is one that I stole
from Monacan [Assumed
Spelling] poet,
Karen Wood [Assumed
Spelling], who is here today.
And she said that she asked Sherman
Aleslie [Assumed Spelling] this
question and it stumped
him and that he got away
without really answering it.
So the question is what is the
biggest risk you've ever taken
as a writer, and that's the tricky
part, as a writer, not as a person?
What's the biggest risk?
>> Linda LeGarde Grover:
Writing nonfiction.
>> Deborah Miranda: Okay, how come?
>> Linda LeGarde Grover: How come?
I think there's a reason that I went
to fiction and I found it was easier
to tell the story with that little
barrier, that little veil between me
as the person responsible
for this particular story
at this particular time and then
whoever reads it or hears it
or receives it in some way.
And so I actually haven't had
- I really haven't had the guts
yet to take the risk of writing
nonfiction, though I might.
>> Deborah Miranda: Okay.
>> Stephen Graham Jones: Nonfiction
is scary, it's like standing
in front of everybody and slowly
taking all your clothes off,
you know?
It's a weird thing.
I don't understand -
nonfiction is wonderful and fun,
but it's so difficult and scary.
The biggest risk I've taken,
I guess I'm still taking it.
When I first started out writing
my publishers wanted - they said,
hey, you're American Indian.
And I said, yeah - it wasn't
that interesting to me,
but it was interesting to them,
it's a marketing hug, you know?
And they said why don't you
go by your family's name,
Calf Looking [Assumed Spelling],
and they said that'll
sell books, that's exotic?
And I thought, well, I do want to
sell books, but then I thought also
that it'd be a much bigger coup if
I can make it as a boring old Jones,
then it's all on my writing ability
or inability or whatever, you know?
Whereas, if I were still a Calf
Looking then I would always be
wondering are people picking
up my book because that looks
like a whole sentence or what,
I mean what is it, you know?
So I'm still taking that.
>> Deborah Miranda: So
you're not [inaudible]?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: No, no.
>> Deborah Miranda: All right.
Eric?
>> Eric Gansworth: I think
I probably did it unaware,
and that was to kind of recognize
at some point that I was writing
about the nuances of very
small tribal politics
and that do not really speak to
a larger audience in its nuances.
I worked very briefly for the
Administration for Native Americans
and this is how I discovered
how insular my work was.
That I was working, you know,
you're doing grant reading.
And one of the employees came
up and knocked on my door
and said can we speak
to you for a minute?
And I thought, oh,
what have I done now?
And said, well, you are affiliated
with two of the only three tribes
that refuse to have a relationship
with the Federal Government,
can you tell us why?
And I didn't realize it,
I guess I had assumed
when you're deeply inside
of something you assume
that many other groups are
along those same lines.
So inadvertently I just rolled them
up, very insular tribal politics.
>> Deborah Miranda:
Okay, and that was a risk
because of readership and interest?
>> Eric Gansworth: Yes, I think
probably, yes, it's too obscure
for a general reader and
I think the community I'm
from is probably mortified that I
wrote about such insular things.
So I think I wrote a
book for four people.
>> Deborah Miranda: Oh, that's
risky, all right, in many ways.
Okay, so my next question
I'm going to steal
from Dorothy Ellison [Assumed
Spelling], this is the question
that she always asks
during her workshops -
what is the story you
cannot die without telling?
What is the story still
ahead that you haven't yet?
>> Stephen Graham Jones:
That's terrifying
because this werewolf one is
the one I always wanted to tell.
>> Deborah Miranda: Oh, no.
>> Stephen Graham Jones:
So I'm going to die now.
>> Deborah Miranda: The
rapture is upon you.
All right.
Linda, any ideas?
>> Linda LeGarde Grover: What
I'm working on now maybe,
which is another part of the story
that continues the
fictional extended family,
the fictional Mozhay Point
Reservation in Northern Minnesota,
which brings us into some really,
really difficult issues having to do
with foster homes and home
placements and experiences.
And so I certainly hope I live
long enough to finish this.
It's a story that I
would like to tell.
I'm not the only person with a
story like that, but I can tell -
but that's what I hope to do.
>> Deborah Miranda: Okay.
Anything come to mind?
>> Eric Gansworth: I think that I'm
kind of in the process of doing it.
Usually when I'm starting
a new project I look
to see what I've been avoiding.
Because I find as a writer that
where I'm most tense is probably
where the most interesting
material is going to come from.
And after several novels I realized
that I was writing a pattern
of childhood, childhood,
childhood, early adulthood,
and there was a whole gap of
seven years of middle school
to high school that were just
so traumatizing and horrifying
that I pretended they do not
exist for most of my career.
And so gradually over the last
few years I've been working on it,
and it's tough, it's tougher
than I thought it was going to be
because you have to
relive some of it but then
at the same time it
seems like it's also some
of the material that's been
the most important to me.
I guess it dwells most inside and
I've been refusing to let it out.
>> Deborah Miranda: Go ahead?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: We
should make a writing team
because I write really good from
like 12 years old to 17 years old.
>> Deborah Miranda: There you go.
Well, that's interesting,
the whole conversation there,
because I really think writing
what we're most afraid of is kind
of the whole point
of writing, right?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: You know
what I'm most afraid of is people
with dog heads, that terrifies me.
Like that's my nightmare, I'm going
to walk around a corner and walk
into a chest, and I'm going
to be like, excuse me, sir.
And I'm going to look up and there's
going to be a dog head there.
That's going to be the
end of it, you know?
But that's why I write
about werewolves
because that's basically
what they are, you know?
I keep thinking if write on the
page well enough or well enough
for myself that I can
move on to the next thing,
but it just makes it more
real and more scary, you know?
>> Deborah Miranda: It's
supposed to capture it, you know,
provide some safety there.
Last question here I think
and then we'll do q-and-a.
I wanted to know, I know that you're
all teachers, you all teach writing
in some way, and I'm wondering, a,
how does teaching create a writing
affect, you as a writer or, b,
you can pick, you have options
here, b, does being somebody
who identifies as indigenous
and probably teaches mostly
non-indigenous students how does
that affect your writing,
if it does?
>> Linda LeGarde Grover: I
don't teach creative writing.
>> Deborah Miranda: Oh, okay.
>> Linda LeGarde Grover:
That's fine.
I teach a variety of American
Indian studies classes,
and one of them is
a literature class.
But, yes, it is true
that where I work most
of the students are non-Native.
And how does that affect my writing?
In some ways I think it
perhaps strengthens it
and even perhaps eases it,
knowing that there's stories
that can be told and that must
be cared for and protected
and then perhaps passed
on in that way.
And so and I also think that
I perhaps gain a little bit
of understanding of some things in
the world outside of Indian country
through reading the papers
that my students write.
It's a real eye opener and also a
real privilege and a treat a lot
of times to read their
perceptions and what they have taken
out of a novel and want
to give back to me.
Of course, the problem is
that students that really want
to please me, you know, their grade
doesn't depend on their pleasing me.
And so the perceptions
of those students I think
that it's a great help.
I hadn't thought about
that till you asked that.
So, yes, thank you for asking.
I'm going to go read
some more papers.
>> Deborah Miranda: Wow, that's
the first time that's happened.
Eric, how about you?
>> Eric Gansworth: I would
say that I was kind of unaware
that I was writing from an
indigenous perspective at first.
I was not a particularly avid reader
and I probably started reading
because it was the era of
pre-VCR and so the only way
to relive movies was to read
these really terrible novels
that were made for horror films.
And I wandered into reading
Carrie and Salem's Lot,
thinking they were non-realizations.
And, wow, these are way better
than a lot of those others.
And so that kind of was
the beginning of my desire
to be a writer, was having
discovered Stephen King.
And in college I had
written a novel and shown it
to my creative writing professor,
and I thought I had really written
like a Stephen King-ish novel.
And when he handed it
back he said, well,
that was a really fascinating
novel of the reservation,
but what were those
monsters doing in there?
And it was like a very illuminating
moment, like I had no idea
that I had in fact already
started to internalize
that story and refracted.
And so at that point I said I
guess this is what I'm writing.
And the monsters gradually wander
back in every now and then,
but mostly after his comment I
saw that my family offered me
such riches to tell about that I
wanted to do their stories right.
>> Stephen Graham Jones:
Yes, it's the same for me.
Like when I write about a
zombie who comes and messes
up Sunday dinner it's really
the time my uncle got drunk
and came to see us.
But I'll try to tackle the
first part of that question,
teaching creative writing, how
does that impact my writing?
It makes me have to be accountable
because I tell my students,
I just try to condition them
such that they spell okay
with four letters, not two letters,
and they don't put
their prose together
with just and though and but.
There's this whole litany of things
that I think produces
better writing.
So then when I'm at my own
keyboard doing my stuff I'll notice
if I use just like three times
in a paragraph I'm like, man,
Caitlin from class is going to
see that, I've got to be better.
And so I think it makes me better,
it makes me a more
aware writer anyways.
And I think the more you can be on
the page the better author you are.
>> Deborah Miranda: I agree.
Okay, at this point we're going to
open it up to questions and answers
from the audience, and we're going
to have a microphone that goes
around so if you have a
question just raise your hand
and we'll bring the mike to you.
Anybody have questions?
>> I'd love to know who have
been your particular individual
inspirations in your life,
your lives, when you were young
as readers and then when
you were actually thinking
about constructing literature?
And those are maybe
two different things,
but who have been your
inspiration as reader and as writer?
>> Eric Gansworth: I was
kind of the reader kid,
I mean even though I was not
a particularly huge reader,
like everybody in my family
hated reading, so that I liked it
at all was kind of an anomaly.
And I discovered, the Cliff notes
for my cousins, they don't want
to read their books, they knew
I read books so they asked me
to read their books and tell them
what it was they were supposed
to have read for class.
And I discovered The Red Pony and
To Kill a Mockingbird very early,
and book now called The Pig Man.
And I just found that I was being
moved by them, that I really wanted
to meet these characters and it was
kind of that love of Stephen King
after discovering that you could do
something beyond the novelization.
And the tremendous luxury of right
as I was beginning to be serious
about writing, Love
Medicine came out,
so I was 19 when Love Medicine
came out and I thought, oh,
well, this is what you can do.
And so Louise Erdrich's, her first
novel was a really defining moment
for me as a writer.
>> Stephen Graham Jones:
You know, I started out,
by the time I was 12 I had read
all of Louis L'amour's novels.
Up until that time
there were 95 of them,
and I thought they were
true, they were gospel.
They're not exactly best friends
of the Indian or anything,
but I loved them, you
know, I loved them.
And I read novelizations,
too, the horror movies.
I remember seeing inside Jason
Borghese's [Assumed Spelling] head
was so cool and everything.
But then, yes, I graduated -
I don't know if I graduated,
graduated suggests a hierarchy - I
moved like laterally into Pynchon,
Thomas Pynchon, and then
Thomas Pynchon was a gateway
to Jerald Bezener [Assumed
Spelling].
And then from tracking down Jerald
Bezener, everybody around him,
I did - this sounds corny that
I would say Love Medicine, too,
but Love Medicine really was a
transformative work for a lot
of us, I suspect, you know?
It did hit me hard.
I've read that book a lot
of times trying to figure
out its peculiar magic, and I don't
think I've figured it out yet.
And, yes, Stephen King,
too, definitely [inaudible]
and just comic books, too.
I grew up on comic books, you know?
I still read comic
books all the time.
If I could draw I wouldn't
have any novels published
because I'd be trying to
do comic books, you know?
>> Linda LeGarde Grover:
My inspiration I guess would be
the stories that I listened to
and eavesdropped on when I
was a child because I was one
of those kids who read a lot but
was also directed to get my nose
out of the book and
go outside and play.
And then I would hang
around and eavesdrop,
and so probably annoyed
the adults very much.
But that became like
reading a book for me,
and I've always loved reading.
I mean I read everything
I saw when I was a child.
My uncle was - one of my uncles was
a janitor in our school district
and he actually was supposed to be
disposing of a bunch of old books,
and a ton of them were about
Russia during the Czar time,
novels, history books.
And he was supposed to toss them
out or incinerate them or whatever,
and he brought them up to our house.
And so when I was a kid I had
a great time reading those.
He brought me a big box of Reader's
Digests from the '40s and '50s
and I loved reading those, too.
I love Agatha Christie.
I love Louise Erdrich's stuff
and for me the Erdrich book
for me was Tracks when it came out
and Fleur Pillager
[Assumed Spelling].
So I loved to listen and
to read, and eventually
after awhile I started
to write them I guess.
>> Stephen Graham Jones: You
know, that compulsion to read,
I had that too when I was a kid.
I'd run out of Reader's Digests
so I'd go to my grandma's kitchen
and spin her Lazy Susan and it
would stop and I'd pull out of a can
of soup and I'd read
everything on that soup can.
Yes, then I'd do the beans and
then I'd move on down the -
I just had to be reading,
if I wasn't thinking
in words I didn't feel like I
belonged on the planet, you know?
>> The transformative
power of humor,
you are a very literate
group, I wonder if any
of you has a George Custer joke?
>> Eric Gansworth: I'm not sure
it's a joke, but a major setting
for this novel that I just read from
and it's a major plot line, as well,
is a stand these kids take
against an ice cream stand
called Custard's Last Stand.
>> Deborah Miranda: Do
you have a Custer joke?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: I
don't have a Custer joke.
>> Linda LeGarde Grover: I
don't have a Custer joke,
but I did read a book about
Custer that was a big little book,
does anybody know what those
are, from a long time ago
and we had a box of those, too.
At some point George Custer's
wife and her friends were afraid
of being attacked by Indians
and somebody told them
if they pretended they were drunk
that the Indians were really
afraid of drunk women.
I thought, well, of course.
Anyway, so I was kind of
fascinated by that part in the book.
I can't help it, I
still laugh about it
and I don't know where it came from.
You need to put that in something
you write, it can be true.
>> Hi. This week begins Indigenous
Week [inaudible] events going
on around the world.
Do you see your writing reflecting
indigenous issues outside
of the United States
[inaudible] in any kind of way
or movements, indigenous people?
>> Stephen Graham Jones: I do think
a lot of the concerns and issues
that many people face in America,
yes, I mean they're not all the same
across the whole globe
I don't think,
but I think some of
them are, you know?
I mean appropriation, thievery,
all that stuff, you know?
I think that, I mean it's
not the same everywhere,
but if you reduce it to a
thumbnail enough it's probably
true [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Stephen Graham Jones:
Not intentionally for me,
if it happens it's a complete
happy accident, you know?
>> Eric Gansworth:
Well, my grandparents
and their siblings all went
to Carlisle Indian School,
and I have to say that in
Canada they've recognized
or at least admitted that the
residential schools was cultural
genocide and the United States has
refused to make that admission.
So in that way my work is -
it kind of draws on that a lot
and their experiences and the
ramifications I see in my family
and friends from home,
two generations later.
And so I think that - do I
wish the US would rise up
and actually admit that that's true?
Yes.
>> Linda LeGarde Grover: I don't
know what they would say then,
what would they say next?
I can't imagine that.
>> Eric Gansworth: That's part
of the problem, there would have
to be some kind of further response.
>> Stephen Graham Jones: Yes.
>> Eric Gansworth: Yes, we did that.
>> Linda LeGarde Grover:
Yes, I know.
So I write a lot about - my research
field is affects of policies,
boarding school policies and the
boarding school era and termination,
policies on individuals
and families.
And so I see these kind of
the destruction of people
and the destruction through
policies that people invent
that they say were done
with the best of intentions.
I just have a really hard
time swallowing that one,
and so I see that worldwide.
And I parallel, when I'm
thinking of things and writing
about things I often
parallel them to, well,
at that point in history say
what was my grandmother doing?
And I think about the terrible
destruction that has been brought
and how just a regular
woman just living her life,
having her children taken away
from her, and all the things.
This isn't only my family,
its many families' stories.
And so if it's many families'
stories in the world that I know,
what stories are like this
worldwide, how do we keep -
and I guess I can say
we, as human beings,
how do we keep hurting
other people in the name
of what we have decided
is a righteous thing?
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.